let's cool it off our test driver matt
has cured reels off widespread
preconceptions about scotus that they're
sensible cheap and a bit boring process
the father on his fourth he says the new
octavia RS proves this is all untrue
it's a lot of fun to drive is not
sensible and it's a little more
expensive than a gold GTI is pissing
toilet at zengo [ __ ] the Octavia RS s
appeal has more to do with speed than
with being sensible so we shift down in
the precise six gear transmission and
enter the curve with engine roaring this
is where the RS is most fun mastering
wide or tight curves with a bump and
security the car feels much more agile
than it looks
monta says a sporty appearance is part
of a sporty driving experience the
Octavia RS has a grim face the RS logo
is the only hit of its power and
aficionados are the only ones likely to
recognize it
the front apron is divided into three
parts and has a spoiler lip the car also
boasts big rims
at the rear of the four and a half meter
chassis is a roof edge spoiler and dual
exhaust but the real sportiness of the
RS is under the hood
you
the RS has the same sporty engine as the
gold GTI protester notes that the
Octavia RS is nonetheless practical a
few twists of the wrist and storage
space increases from 610 to 1740 liters
the interior pampers the driver with
top-flight accoutrements and a large
multifunction monitor all the necessary
information is also shown between the
speedometer and the TOC the seats are
partly leather and have good side
support generous space in the back seat
makes the RS hatchback a good family car
model jaan maanta submerge the interior
and the satnavs huge monitor he likes
that the controls are automatically
displayed when your hand approaches the
monitor and he likes the sporty
carbon-fiber look in the details one
optic 10 minutes on audit leash bought
this kind the SCOTUS sports suspension
and progressive steering enabled it to
maneuver precisely and directly on rural
roads the steering can be set softer for
city and highway driving
montes underscores that the octavia RS
doesn't sacrifice its suitability for
long drives to sportiness the RS is 162
kilowatt 2-liter TSI engine pays off on
the highway the car can accelerate
powerfully even in 6th gear and it's
prints from 0 to 100 km/h in 6.9 seconds
the gasoline engines 350 newton meters
of torque are reached very quickly for a
very powerful feel the RS hatchback has
a top speed of 244 kilometers an hour
skoda says the gasoline-powered RS burns
6.2 litres per 100 kilometers but to
enjoy everything the RS can do we'll
have to expect fuel consumption of 10
litres per 100 kilometers but matta says
those 10 liters are worth it for all the
fun the Octavia RS provides thrifty
driver should consider the RS with a
diesel engine and the hatchback version
the RS has very high utility value
available as a sedan it's also very well
suited for everyday use
my father montes sums up the octavia RS
is a very sporty car that hugs the road
well handles well comes in to chassis
variants which is rare and offers more
power than you usually need but that
you'll enjoy having how about down to my
huntin if you want to move fast in a
hatchback bring along at least thirty
thousand two hundred fifty euros
you